[Music]
in that backfired news submitted by
Courage the Cowardly Dog mr. Shah
Arizona's positive ticketing campaign
gets backlash from Twitter what the hell
is a positive ticketing you go oh we're
driving 64 miles an hour they're like
yeah you got the cops trying to come at
it from a positive they still gotta go
[ __ ] heart attack
I'm driving 60 miles now what the [ __ ]
they pop confetti when you dude I want a
positive SWAT team good I'll be so cool
there's a positive SWAT team they break
the [ __ ] door down keep your [ __ ]
hands up cuz it's [ __ ] party time
there's two guys with wrenches and they
pull out the screwdrivers and start
fixing your door sorry sorry about that
attack dog come out [ __ ] jump on your
thing's gonna fight you play just like
you city in Arizona the local news
outlet tweeted this out week sure today
police are kicking off a campaign to
promote good driving officers will be
pulling people over who are following
traffic Wow God but instead of a ticket
you'll get a coupon for a free drink at
Circle K give us your reaction to this
new initiative no stress you like don't
waste my [ __ ] time bro like what if
someone's in a hurry yeah like what [ __ ]
you get pulled over and they waste like
20 ever minutes guys - trying to remove
the stigma around tickety but they're
like you get a free drink at Sur okay
I'm like [ __ ] I don't even drink soda
if they want to do that what would be
dope is if there's like a free get out
of court card oh god I got to be
equivalent like if you if you speed but
you have to go to court you have to do
all this legal [ __ ] I don't want a
free [ __ ] drink
I want another thing that's gonna
balance out the court [ __ ] true yeah
it's like you have good you know driving
skills and whatever and they're like
they want to compliment you but then
they give you a free like pass for
something like next time you can speed
but because you've been such a you've
been on good behavior yeah because if
circle-k
mailed me a coupon and I open it at my
house I'd still throw it in the garbage
no we're Circle kids in a free drinker
it's like a free Mike's Hard Lemonade
tall boy I don't think that kind of
drink yeah probably not it's probably a
error hey you're not drinking and
driving wants to come another dream
right tom boy yeah so that's when there
was a lot of backlash they were like
what the [ __ ] don't interrupt my day
yeah and give me a heart attack by
pulling me over over some stupid free
drink coupons Canada Arizona especially
if you're like already used to getting
profiled and yeah holy [ __ ] yeah I have
a heart attack if I was Mexican I used
to have a cholo because in Arizona
you're Mexican right
they're randomly stopping Mexicans at
stores and all that [ __ ] gotcha oh I
thought you were talking about you have
a heart attack if you're Mexican because
of the obesity rate for Mexicans that
too
wow it's just a fact yes you don't hear
a peep out of me
no peace oh I had a cholo card cuz I
bought it off eBay from this troller
chick and it was like all all decked out
with like rims and like that like base
you know how they used to have the
little person yeah so tinted windows and
[ __ ] and I got pulled over all the time
cuz they thought I was gangster and then
I roll down the window they're like oh
never mind
get the spinor hubcaps and [ __ ] oh those
immediately like it's my birthday yeah
I'm like yes they're like oh have you
been drinking and driving I'm like no no
like I'll never mind so that means you
just drive like [ __ ]
nobody Bunko their profile a girl baby
driver of a [ __ ] Beast okay watch out
it's not fun to driver thinking it's not
yeah you get there don't yet oh dude
so yesterday I was I was I was getting
lunch I wanted a bond nice and I was
behaving at victim abandonment and so I
pull up this place and I I'm like oh
[ __ ] fifteen minute parking this is
gonna suck so I set a timer on my phone
for 15 minutes from now and then I'm in
there of course it takes forever it's
not it's not ready in time so I go out
there and I feed the meter and I look
next to me and I see that the traffic
cop guide has has part meter man he's
walking over
and then there's this chick he I think
for a second I'm like I could go feed
that meaner too but I did it and then I
stood there and I watched him ticket it
and then I watched his chick come out
and I sort of like watched it watched
her get ticketed like I was watching
someone die like I was like I was like I
could have stopped this but I just want
to see what it looks like that's like a
kid killing a cat because he wants to
see what it's like to die - me too
so I was that I was at H Mart which is
like Asian supermarket so you already
know Asians can't drive right no one's
ever paying attention so as I was coming
out of the supermarket as I was coming
out there's this lady with a shopping
cart she was pushing it but she wasn't
paying attention I think she was like ah
whatever vegetables are whatever that
she had and then there's a car coming
this way and the two dudes the two Asian
is there locked eyes so yeah I could
already see the car come and just hit
that shopping cart and make it fly and I
was there now it's kind of like you like
kind of hope he was gonna happen at your
booth if the cars can be really fast I
want to stop there like I don't want her
to die what are you watching there
shopping that's just enough for it to
knock the shopping cart over and then
finally like she was like oh [ __ ] like
this and then he stand on the brakes on
like no one died that's too bad I know
that's like that scene in spider-man 2
with talking wire where he stops please
spider-man and then he sees some chick
go down and he's like taco remember
jackasses meter maid know dressed up in
a maid outfit and every time the parking
meter attendant came he would [ __ ]
put coins inside they're like I want to
write this ticket so bad funny so back
to this story here with the positive
chicky ticketing campaign so the police
department and now it's like hold on
wait wait wait I don't know
this got messed up but we are not
pulling over people like drivers this is
only for pedestrians and biking people
that are biking like you're walking good
bicyclists yes oh they said you're gonna
be observing pedestrians and bicyclists
who follow traffic laws thank you for
not jaywalking walk up to them
afterwards and then thank them by giving
them the free drink coupon and there's
that still scary as [ __ ] what you're
like coming towards me move you're
approaching them you're just like what
the [ __ ] so they're saying that this is
all about consensual interactions I
don't want no cops near me no yes so
they're saying like one example would be
an officer at station and at school a
cop might see a student biking with a
helmet on and then later on they
appreciate that they're following the
law yeah so they're just saying this is
that what they treat it out positive
ticketing campaign the purpose of the
event is to positively engage with the
public regarding laws pertaining to
bicyclists scooter and pedestrian safety
during this campaign at temp a police
will not be proactively stopping
vehicles bicycles scooters or
pedestrians now you know what they need
to do is just Flashdance that'll get
them on the good side with people what's
fun like [ __ ] flash mob you know like
Flashdance I like that but like like the
flash mob style and the [ __ ] water
bucket or they just have a different
kind of uniform like Boas or like
something that makes you go like oh it's
the nice copies giving me a coupon yeah
you're not like oh [ __ ] what did I do
yeah I think that it's the the delivery
system for the message is wrong like if
they hire a bunch of minds to come up to
people engage with them and then give
them a coupon or something Oh minds are
too stressful yeah cuz he said like
you're like oh no I trapped in a box how
about a clown god
but that's a jerk mine right I'm talking
about like nice minds in person period
evers jerk minds are the ones you like
to make you feel like you're in about
French ones are the pass whole one nice
mine is just you know that's [ __ ] a
murder or do they have like the flower a
little flower a white face and then they
got like upper ray I've seen that like
the cartoon line yeah yeah a nice mime
that he's talking about what is the kind
by the kind of mine put you in a box
yeah what are you doing then instead
he's like ah no he's got like a little
rope and he's like pulling himself and
then he goes to office he goes down some
stairs
yeah he goes downstairs because he goes
on an elevator then he goes now we need
we need a cop in a costume like a dog
outfit or something that's gonna like
remember me with the bone yeah like so
yeah yeah or just not the firefighters
do this everyone likes the firefighter
true it's the purpose because we want
the police to like look good that's
impossible if they all just wore short
shorts I would be like hell yeah this is
the party [ __ ] that's pretty good there
we go
that's true the YMCA cops in Hollywood I
when I lived there they used to like
actually have the horse cops and they
were they would ticket almost people
it's pretty sad because you think like
oh it's the horse cops but then they
were like occupation and then the horses
[ __ ] on them you give a ticket for them
[ __ ] on the sidewalk and on the
horse shits on the side exactly dude I
don't know after [ __ ] I feel like the
riot control I've seen a lot of horse
but they have like our tax dollars pay
the clean Hollywood every every day so
every night with pressure washers yeah
really it's still healthy yeah they just
hose it down but how they don't like use
it any soap smells like urine at night
like Hollywood Highland yeah and then by
the next morning they hose it all down
that's crazy they clean it every day and
it still looks like it way and it smells
like [ __ ]
yeah yeah come on it's great guys
[Music]
[Music]